I'll mention something that's sitting
outside I can I can see it from here
that people might be interested in so I
I have been and still am a
fervent believer in cold therapy so
using using ice baths as a means of
controlling it inflammation as a means
of mood elevation oh mood elevation big
time oh it's unbelievable
and generally my Approach has been to
get a chest freezer of some type and
fill it with ice Etc and that works but
they get really disgusting really
quickly and they all do dude I bought
one of the machines the real Pro ones
yeah and then you're stuck with this
thing
that is an eyesore and you don't do it I
tried to sell it I couldn't yes so I
ended up
because I realized how much of a
how significant a lever this is for
improving my quality of life just on a
daily basis like and I'll backstep for a
second and just say one thing that I
learned from Tony Robbins
to give him credit and I don't know if
he came up with this but
is this sequence of State
story strategy so it's like fix your
state first
only then can you come up with an
enabling story and only then can you
come up with an effective strategy
because if you're like feeling shitty
and you're sleep deprived and you're
kind of depressed or anxious or whatever
you try to come up with a strategy
meaning how to fix something you're not
going to come up with a good strategy
generally generally speaking so it's
like fix your fix your physical
State first
then you can come up with an enabling
story then come up with an effective
strategy so the the state piece is very
important there aren't that many ways I
have found to change State exercise is
one but it requires generally a fair
amount of time
heat is also effective but again
generally requires say
it doesn't sound like a much but it's
like 15 to 30 minutes let's just say in
a sauna very effective cold is the
fastest it's just the fastest for me and
I've gone without cold therapy because
I've not wanted to get some huge chest
freezer or a pro model I am also going
to be getting a pro model they get all
scummy though and then you got to put
chlorine in them and it's it's a lot
yeah this is all that but I went on
Amazon and I found something called the
cold pod which you set up in like five
minutes you fill it with water from a
hose you put ice in and it works
perfectly well as a cold plush and I I
ended up buying Yeti cooler to store ice
in so I have a few days of ice
and it's let's see what would it be it
would be like
if you were standing maybe it's hip
height
and it's probably
three feet in diameter and you get in
you just kind of crouch in there
and it works [__] great it works
really well
and it costs like 150 or 200 bucks maybe
I don't know maybe it's 100 bucks it's
not crazy 169. there you go and I've
been really impressed with this thing
it's very basic
and even when it's been very hot outside
like you put in two bags of ice and you
let it sit for 20 minutes it's gonna get
pretty cold it's not gonna be 30 degrees
but it's probably going to be mid 50s
depending on how much water you have in
there Pro tip the more water you have in
there the more ice you're going to need
to cool it so don't fill it all the way
up to the top
I fill it up like halfway and then add
the ice
and it's been a game changer for me this
is a plastic trash can Dude well no it's
not a plastic trash can I mean probably
it is made this shake because it
probably cost them like 15 bucks to
build one of these things yeah it's not
a trash can I just to be clear I mean
it's look it's we're not talking about a
[__] Maserati but here's what's nice
about it it's very easy to set up it's
not a trash can because that makes it
sound like it's like mid-chest height
and hard it's easy to pack you can
actually travel with it if you want to
travel with it so I would just say for
people who have how do you travel with
it oh it's super easy man oh it folds up
yeah it folds up you stick it in a bag
you can take it with you it's super easy
in your hotel room
yeah the hotel loves 50 gallons of water
spilling out
so for those people who have perhaps
heard about the benefits of cold therapy
but have avoided it because it's too
expensive it's too time consuming
whatever this is a way to test it and I
would just say this is a low hurdle way
to test it out and I used it earlier
today gives fantastic changed my day so
that's the cult yep and there are a
bunch of other options that look
basically identical I just went with the
one with the best reviews
nothing fancy